turn the music down turn the music down
[Music]
hey guys
second time I need one I need somebody
to come to the door
music stays off party's over
here
foreign
I have her cell phone number too
okay
hello Miss what's your name
is Anna do you live here yeah yes hey
did Megan talk to you earlier I know
okay does Megan live here
Logan
sorry we
she is at the club
she's 21. I'm just going to bed I have a
couple friends over but this is my idea
have you talked to Maddie tonight yes I
have she's at the corner Club okay is
she did she tell you anything about
anything that happened earlier or
anything like that honestly not really
I'm I've just been here
my roommates are 21. I just wanted to go
to bed we're not here for we're not here
to talk about the alcohol stuff okay
okay
um but this is the second noise
complaint we've had here tonight within
two hours I'm sorry okay fine so this
time it was the blonde gal and the guy
in the back porch playing music okay so
I sincerely apologize about that okay
I'm just going to bed
so just so you understand you could be
getting a misdemeanor Citation for this
which means you have to go in front of a
judge and explain why you couldn't keep
the people in your house quiet okay
we've already talked to Maddie once and
told her the same thing okay the only
reason she's not gonna take it is
because she's not standing here in front
of me but I'm telling you right now if
we have to come back you're getting a
ticket okay so I will have to go see a
judge I'm fine right now you're not
gonna take it right now I'm just trying
to go to bed right now I mean I I
understand you guys you're
coming here
I'm I'm just going okay well understand
that you're responsible for the
residents so whoever else is here if
they have a safe way to get home you
need to kick them out or tell them to
come inside and be quiet okay because
the houses that are on this hill all the
way around here we can hear you from
Clear down the road when we're coming up
here we can hear the music and that's
I'm so sorry we're past the point of
having polite conversations okay and
neighbors are being kept up okay I'm
sorry it's just like is the the blonde
gal and the guy up there are they
roommates too
I'm sorry the blonde gal and the the guy
that's upstairs are they roommates too
none of my roommates oh okay
okay
so do you understand 100 I understand
what's going to happen I'm gonna tell
everyone sorry
figure it out and I'm not saying that
you gotta tell everybody they have to
leave but I'm telling you any outside
music and the loud yelling needs to be
done okay because we're not next time
you're getting a ticket okay okay and if
you get a misdemeanor citation the
university is not going to take kindly
to it yeah so not only do you have to go
see a judge I've never had to deal with
this ever and we don't want to start now
I don't ever remember having to come
here so I understand you guys are having
to get together but people have a way of
taking the invitation and using it as an
excuse to get out of control and be loud
Advantage exactly okay I'm so sorry it's
okay I just I just hope for your sake
that your friends don't put you in a
position where you get the citation and
you have to go to court to defend
yourself from your friend's Behavior
make sense okay thank you okay you wanna
get a good phone number for her yep and
just remember the dean of students
office probably will be contacting you
about this as well
about student code of conduct issues
thank you so much any questions no
questions okay make sure your friends
don't put you in a bad position tell
them it's time to be done okay there's
like no yeah it was the two that were
around the back we had to holler at them
to turn the music down so all right guys
I'm so sorry nope that's all right you
take care okay thank you
[Applause]